Well,
I'm,
I'm very concerned about the traditional
foods versus imitation foods.
I still find people asking me,
um,
about soy butter that doesn't contain
trans fats because now they know trans
fats are bad.
They're still asking me about a
substitute foods and imitations and
engineered foods and foods with added
this or removed that.
And what I want them to understand is
that the whole traditional foods are
best,
even if they can't afford the best
quality version of beef or eggs or milk,
they ought to be consuming beef or eggs
or milk instead of Ersatz foods.
Um,
and,
and I'm also concerned about a plant
based diet for,
um,
for pregnant mothers and for young
children.
Um,
there is a trend in many urban areas for
young children to be vegetarians and I,
I gather from parents and from
journalists that it's the children who
are requesting to be vegetarians.
Um,
and this is presented as charming.
Once Johnny finds out that I'm the,
the chicken breast comes from a chicken.
He can't bear to eat his friend.
The chicken.
Well,
um,
our son Julian,
who's three,
um,
helps me take apart chickens regularly.
He completely understands that his
friends,
the farm animals are also the foods we
eat.
We are omnivores and nature created us
as omnivores.
Um,
I think there are a lot of things
five-year-olds might want.
They might want junk and they might want
junk television.
Um,
they might want to be vegetarians,
but it's not a good time for a person to
be a vegetarian.
If in adulthood you've been well fed 'em
in your mother's womb and at her breast
and in your growing years,
you want to experiment with a high
quality vegetarian diet or even have a
very carefully planned Vegan Diet.
I think that's acceptable,
but I,
I don't think it's right for children to
be raised as vegetarians even if they
ask.
The good news also is that there now I'm
ethically sound and ecologically sound
ways to be an omnivore.
And so I would urge you,
if you are,
if you are conscientious about these
matters,
to find the farmers who care for animals
and care for plants and care for the
environment and shop from them.